what's up I'm Benji I'm Joel we're the
Madden brothers and uh we stopped by
today to play some songs for details.com
and the first song we're going to play
is California rain uh it's from our new
record greetings from California
2 little darl don't you cry even
californ sometimes we can make it we got
to try baby I believe in
California
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah let me take you back people the
light before the CR before we made sound
all I wanted was to make my mother
Crown she told me something from the
side of town makes it
out before we created before they hated
before anyone
anticipated we just want to make it they
said you crazy nothing's ever changing
so back for my things and Ed out towards
the ocean in my imagination
C's
she hello I'm
glad here comes the
[Music]
rain don't you
cry even
[Music]
cfor sometimes we can make it we got to
try baby I
believe some's waiting on the other side
There's No Limit we can't touch the
sky baby I
believe in California
R
[Music]
yeah a long time coming a long road
running you know what I'm saying if you
ever wanted something so bad you could
taste it s until you make it and you
know when you got it no one else could
ever take it when I man she wasy was
happy
nevered to but the
stor all the tribulations for the five
STS waiting you just got to recre
in
[Music]
myin hell I'm soad finally made
it here comes the
[Music]
r cry
even we can make it we got to try baby I
believe
that some's waiting on the other
side the limit we can't touch the
sky baby I
believe in California
R
[Music]
yeah
everything you
was
Califor rain on me
everything was see
cfor r on me
everything what
on on me everything in what it see
California
[Music]
rain
great